steve kaufman here
um just come back from cross-country
skiing at cypress which is 20 minutes
away cypress mountain
conditions were excellent it was like
mid-winter fresh snow it was maybe three
four degrees below zero centigrade
uh had a good workout for about an hour
and a half two hours
and i'm gonna have dinner soon you hear
my wife
playing the piano um when she stops
playing the piano she's gonna start
making supper i hope that's soon
um today
i am going to uh talk a little bit about
this book
this is a book it's called babble no
more
uh the search for the world's most
extraordinary language learners by
michael
errard i guess you pronounce his name
and this book was sent to me so i
decided to read it and
maybe even i'll write a review on it
uh it's an interesting book for people
who are interested in language learning
it's not the kind of book that gives you
the
you know 10 tips and tricks for
learning languages in two weeks there's
no
secrets there there are lots of nuggets
of useful information
uh it's presented as sort of an
adventure or a treasure hunt
uh he goes traveling around the world
and looking for people whom he calls
hyperglots people who learn lots and
lots of languages
he also talks about famous hyperglots in
history i can't remember all their names
uh and he's sort of looking for
what do they have in common are there
secrets there that can learn
that can help the more
normal language learners uh the great
thing about the book other than the fact
that it's it's i think quite well
written
uh is that he doesn't provide any simple
answers uh you have to draw your own
conclusions sorry i yank my why are
there connecting my
microphone
uh you have to draw your own conclusions
uh i have some you know questions that i
ask why you know hyperglot where's the
dividing line is it you know 10 5
languages 10 languages 20 languages i
mean he talks about people i've learned
50 languages 60 languages it's also not
clear how well these people
speak these languages and there's
generally the feeling throughout the
book that you can only master a smaller
number
uh it's clear in the book that people
have different motives for learning
languages some like our friend professor
alexander argellas really doesn't like
to speak at all and
just learn likes to read and the quote
is attributed to him that most
conversations in english are not very
stimulating why would it be different in
other languages so he just likes to read
i i find that
strange
i kind of like talking to people in
whatever language
it also comes out of the book that mr uh
professor argelias doesn't believe in
mp3 players and prefers to go
jogging with a walkman
which again is like why would you do
that but anyway
different people do different things
that's one thing we have to respect
um
so that
air art here talks about you know is it
the way people study is it something
about their upbringing is it something
in their brain
is it you know what is it that makes
these people um you know able to study
so many languages
um
again there are no conclusions at one
point in the book he says you know do
people study languages in order to
increase their neuroplasticity
or is
are they able to study many languages
because they have increased
neuroplasticity
and this this kind of thing comes up all
the time are they the way they are
because they study languages
uh
or
uh
do they
do is is the way they are preconditioned
for being successful at studying
languages and there's really no
answer
there are areas in the book where he
draws some conclusions which i think are
quite good like
language learners have to be meaning
oriented definitely i study for meaning
i study for things that interest me
in the content of what i'm listening to
or reading
they have to be good at recognizing
patterns absolutely language learning is
about noticing and about recognizing
patterns
and our brain is inherently good at
recognizing patterns but i guess some of
us are better than others
but the skill or the ability to
recognize patterns in language
increases the more we do it
uh so i mean i come away with a feeling
that the more people study the better
they get at that is languages the better
they get at studying languages what's so
unusual
uh
why would people want to learn 50
languages because they like doing it
um i know people when i was young i had
an older friend who would buy balsa wood
and with a raise or cut up small pieces
and then build these
you know
you know old you know china clipper type
schooners sailing ships
paint them put them in a little bottle
and with strings somehow you know erect
the ship with all its sails inside the
bottle
you know i would never do that i
couldn't do that i would go crazy trying
to do that
and he would do it over and over again
um
so people have different interests um do
you know he mentions the fact that the
brains of some of these language
learners are different but well of
course they are as he himself points out
in the book
a pianist very quickly develops a
different brain from a non-pianist so
any activity is going to cause our
brains to develop you know in a slightly
different direction and and make our
brains more fit for a certain kind of
activity none of that is particularly
unusual
um
you know he mentions our friend the ziad
whatever his name was the the lebanese
brazilian who claimed to speak 50
languages and was
invited to a television program in chile
and there were five people there who
spoke the languages that he claimed to
speak and they asked him questions and
he couldn't answer any of them but he's
the only known sort of
maybe fake because the others are for
real i'm disappointed that richard
simcott wasn't in there um he speaks i
don't know 50 or so languages 15 rather
very very well they could have had moses
in there i don't know that moses because
he goes for so many languages i don't
don't know that he achieves a
tremendously high level in in most of
them he may and some of them i just
don't know
uh
but his would have been an interesting
case because he doesn't come from a
multi-lingual environment like some of
the people they mentioned in the book
catalam is mentioned in the book and she
says something like
we learn grammar from language we don't
learn language from grammar which i
think is a very interesting quote so
there's a bunch of nuggets in the book
uh one of the things that i discovered
in reading the book is that chewing gum
is good for studying and so i looked it
up on the internet and what it is is
that if you're chewing you're creating
saliva and that sends insulin around
your body and increases the oxygen
supply to your brain and they figured
that you can even increase the
effectiveness of your studying by 20 by
chewing gum or chewing while you study
hey there's something
uh he talks about you know the
importance of the hippocampus this area
of your brain the importance of dopamine
in other words a sense of satisfaction
and achievement
that spurs you on to more activity it
made me think that of course dopamine
production has increased with exercise
and the exercise also makes your
hippocampus
uh more effective and the hippocampus is
where we kind of manage things in our
brain a little bit that i understand
so exercise is probably good for you too
so you want to run around chewing gum
maybe listen to an mp3 player um
do a lot of those things
i don't know
he sort of at one point he says the only
difference between these hyper glots as
he calls them and ordinary people is
that the hyper gloss are willing to
you know do things that are inherently
boring well i certainly disagree with
that comment because
i don't find it boring i would find
making little sailboats to put in
bottles boring
uh but you know i get back to my check
which i'm studying i
i find it very interesting
i i have mentioned that i'm reading my
my for the second time now second pass
through my book on uh on central
european history in czech and of course
there are words that i
don't understand i get tired of
importing them into link all the time
but
lo and behold on the internet i found a
website which has uh czech you know
lessons on czech history quite a number
of them
so i've imported them into link
and i just love going in there and and
saving the words and phrases from those
texts and that helps me get through the
book here and lo and behold today uh
before going up to ski
i downloaded
some radio programs from radio prague
and one of them
was about this whole issue of the
restitution of church lands
in the czech republic which has been a
big political issue which i've been
following
uh on radio prague and in the czech
newspaper but here there's an article
where
they interview someone who talks about
the history
of church lands
in czechoslovakia
and of course
that then goes through a lot of the
things that i've been reading about in
reading about czech history so that's
not boring to me and i save words and
phrases and review them and i
i learn and i
pardon me learn about the language so
no i don't think
i think it's just a matter of what
people are interested in so the book i
recommended it's full of useful nuggets
one of the things he mentions too that i
believe in and that is that to be a good
language learner you have to be able to
to get away from your language ego
uh
there's a lot of little gems in there
but what's good about it is that he
doesn't present it as
you know this is how you get to be a
good language learner you have to find
it on your own you have to learn about
these different
multi-glotts
uh he pursues them in india he pursues
them in it talks about them in the
amazon he talks about them in africa
he's and he talks about historical
polyglots in europe americans you know
all kinds he's done even did a survey of
polyglots as to what they felt was the
most important element and of course
that generally was
the attitude and and liking the activity
which is not surprising
so
uh you might want to read it i think
it's a good read it has a lot of useful
information
it's written uh in a very sort of uh
entertaining
modest
sort of discovering let's discover
something together kind of way
and there's a lot of useful
little uh tidbits of information
personally i came away more convinced
than ever that uh
you know someone who you know
the first language you learn takes a
long time because you haven't done it
before
if you then want to do another one it
goes much more quickly because you're
more confident you know how to do it
um
now if you learn spanish you can learn
the other romance languages pretty
easily i mean i'm having a lot easier
time with czech than i had with russian
uh having learned chinese i had half the
vocabulary in japanese so
given the fact that our skills get
better and our brain probably gets
more fit in terms of language learning
and that
all languages have related languages so
that once you learn
russian you can learn czech and polish
and ukrainian
uh in less time than you spend on the
first language it's not impossible that
people who dedicated themselves who had
all the time in the world could learn 20
30 languages i don't find that so
strange no more strange than someone who
plays 10 musical instruments uh it's a
matter of what you like to do
um
and and if that's your job so language
learning still comes down to the basics
your attitude your motivation you you
like it you're determined to do it blah
blah blah attitude
two time if you can send eight ten hours
a day of learning languages you can rack
up a lot of languages and the third one
is this whole
idea of noticing identifying patterns
getting and we get better at that the
more we listen the more we read the more
we study languages we get better doing
those things so
as i always say attitude time on task
and developing the ability to notice
what's happening
so there you go babel no more an
interesting read for people who are
interested in learning languages bye for
now